by 2050 two-thirds of the world's
population will live in cities
[Music]
urbanization that is happening faster
than at any time in human history
[Music]
I think that the problem in cities as
they grow is only going to become worse
globally 900 million people are living
in slums cities can't add housing fast
enough today an estimated 1 billion
vehicles are already bringing urban
areas to a standstill
cities consumed three-quarters of the
world's energy each year and are
responsible for around 50% of greenhouse
gas emissions these are challenges our
cities have been facing for decades
but now some city leaders businesses and
even citizens are taking new approaches
to tackling these old problems this is
where technology and imagination meet
together and we create new cities
they're transforming their cities with
technology
so South Korea one of the most connected
digitized cities in the world home to 10
million people this city has a
population density twice that of New
York in Seoul the use of data is seen as
the key to tackling some of the big
challenges of city life like moving its
people around city workers here use
sophisticated technology to understand
that and transform how the city and its
Metro can be run mr. Kim is the manager
of City Hall station
[Music]
don't water I wondered a lot of them you
know your world of awesome
Sun tears are she'd get oh sure you can
know to catch other than a person
focus on that to answer the subway
system transport seven million people
every day it's widely regarded as one of
the best in the world and the entire
network from wheels to workers relies on
continually updating information which
is immoral as a scientist in the
brilliant Sun kagura-san Thomas
generators are more in on your honor two
days of traveling on other events or
higher at emergency in got our harshest
Anika
the speed and frequency of the trains
can be constantly adjusted to keep
everything running smoothly smart
cameras measure how many passengers are
boarding and how quickly and sensors on
the trains and tracks monitor every last
component to provide early warnings when
maintenance is required and prevent
costly breakdown and all of the data
ends up in the hands of this man an MK o
Guinness horse jockey vida sana young
young get to Magana we are your goon mr.
Gardiner's whole [ __ ] Tony Turkish Hamza
da toughest is the city's transport
operation and information service and
this is where mr. Yang and his
controllers get to grips with all the
data not just from the subway but from
the city's buses taxis and roads
[Music]
Chronicle units are booster at home
smarter k ke Baras Freedman resourcing
up we are winner church and the night is
young below young s all also she
wouldn't or Park awake we're here in
tapas their goal is to use the data to
anticipate problems and stop congestion
building up in the first
guru is a bomb and de l'avenir boo boo
boo no Tiger pad in the room kept total
Authority mm what is he bought with
feedback so they use smartphone apps
social media and the web to give
citizens real-time alerts and
alternative routes and keep this mega
city running smoothly
transport is just the start seoul city
planners are using data to better
understand more of the big challenges
this fast-growing city faces from air
pollution to affordable housing high
above the control room there's one man
who keeps tabs on the entire city
his name is Park won-soon systems twist
ha cleaner Switzer
he's a former human rights activist a
political outsider human wander in
patrol
total Authority system has its
privileges
and for the last 7 years he's been the
mayor of Seoul for millennia communities
have been overseen by powerful leaders
like mr. Park but he wants to turn this
on his head handing responsibility to
Seoul's ten million citizens some
deserving jeremy smith our social I wish
part of your question the mayor's office
can plug into real-time data on just
about anything and so from police
call-outs to Street protests to
pollution levels from his office the
mayor can even tell you the real time
price of Apple's he's a bit more coy
about the data the city holds on
individual citizens but the mayor is
clear in his desire to share much of the
information he has
his fingertips
[Music]
Pazuzu let's go on cammy gazanian on
toaster chemistry winning they are
cuckoo cuckoo yawn yawn yawn yawn IRA
Schmendrick loser
tree hugger to you mercy Toro Kaguya so
Chauhan
[Music]
this treasure trove of data is spawning
an industry all of its own there are an
estimated 30,000 startups in South Korea
many of which are offering innovative
solutions to challenges like the city's
housing shortages
[Music]
until this movie
one company uses this open-source data
to pair up young people looking for
accommodation with older citizens who
have rooms to spare it's a tiny offshoot
of an industry that is growing rapidly
in cities across the world by 2020 this
so-called smart city industry will be
worth an estimated 1.5 trillion dollars
there'll be investment in everything
from networks and sensors to new apps
and services from the world's biggest
technology firms to innovative new
startups working from someone's front
room this is the headquarters of flair a
startup based in Kenya it's young
entrepreneurs are working with real time
data sourced from that most ubiquitous
of modern innovations smartphone
[Music]
Kenya's capital Nairobi is emerging as a
vibrant tech hub it is also one of the
fastest-growing cities in the world home
to 4.2 million people it's more than
doubled its population in the last 20
years as in many cities in developing
countries the aging inadequate
infrastructure is struggling to cope
kaitland all cart is one of a new
generation of business leaders trying to
fill some of the gaps
the problem in cities as they grow is
only going to become worse when you
don't actually have the systems in place
to actually coordinate and figure out
how to do that and like I think that the
emergencies are the best example of that
because literally every second and
minute counts it's 10:00 a.m. in central
Nairobi paramedic Nick Makua has been
dispatched to an emergency call but for
many in trouble in the city and
ambulance isn't always the answer but if
you use the Madrid we'll give you the
problem isn't a shortage of ambulances
Nairobi has 150 of them double the
number needed in an average city but the
city has no centralized emergency
service to coordinate them
residents here are faced with 50
different numbers to call for help and
no guarantee when or whether their
ambulance will arrive Nairobi is doesn't
lack resources there's plenty of
ambulances and there's plenty of
hospitals what there isn't is
information - how do you get access to
that starting with tools that we have
today but from that we're building a
system that no one's ever had before so
you can think about it like uber in the
sense that you touch a button and you
know the rest is figured out for you you
just know that the vehicle is coming
your way the app aims to do the job of a
centralized emergency service compiling
real-time data to coordinate and connect
patients in need available ambulances
and the right hospitals or healthcare
providers
Nick and his colleagues reach the
patient 12 minutes after receiving the
call pretty fast for Nairobi where an
ambulance can take up to two hours to
arrive next team soon discovers the
reason for the call a gangrenous toe
excruciating ly painful but not
life-threatening had this man suffered a
stroke or heart attack this smartphone
based system could have helped save his
life
across the developing world innovators
are increasingly exploiting existing
technology to help citizens cope with
their city's overstretched
infrastructure in America innovators are
also looking ahead to the next wave
anticipating data driven technologies
that could help predict problems before
they even happen
Boston Massachusetts is the 10th largest
metropolitan area in America it's home
to 4.8 million residents and while
Boston may be one of the oldest urban
settlements in this country it's fast
developing world leading technology that
could help shape the cities of the
future
this is the mission of MIT sensible city
lab to anticipate the impact of
technology on urban life and use it to
transform the way cities are run
here at mighty we are not in the urban
solutions business we are in the urban
imagination business and this is where
technology and imagination meet together
and we create new cities lead researcher
Fabio Duarte believes that data-driven
technology will change our whole
approach to urban planning when I start
collecting data from nature from
infrastructure from people and putting
this data together then we can see new
things about the city that we're not
able to see it's a mission that takes
Fabio's team to some unlikely parts of
the city as I assume that there is
thorough search there is collecting data
from a sewer isn't a challenge these
researchers relish
so they've brought along a friend meet
Luigi this is Luigi as a whole entire
robot this is the brain of Luigi telling
it how to function
Luigi is a probe built with a big job in
mind we're able to use store samples and
their urine samples in a sewage to
understand people's health patterns and
health behaviors more at the source this
is no crapshoot the samples Luigi is
collecting could help reveal new ways to
manage a public health crisis
from prescription painkillers to heroin
America is in the grip of an opioid
crisis across the country nearly two and
a half million people are hooked on
opioids nationwide these drugs are
responsible for more deaths every day
than gun crime or road traffic accidents
in Massachusetts between 2014 and 2016
opioid deaths rose by an estimated 50
percent
data alone won't stop this opioid
epidemic but data could start to provide
city authorities with the tools to build
better public health plans that's what
the researchers at MIT are hoping in the
lab they're learning how to get data
from Puu we have the sample that we
extracted from the sewage and what we're
gonna do is we're gonna take it and what
we want to extract from it is to
separate out the microbes from it the
bacteria and the viruses and the DNA so
that we can process it for DNA data and
we also want to extract the chemicals
from it so that we have data on chemical
excreted from humans using these
techniques the researchers can learn
when and where there's been a surge in
opioid use or bad batches of heroin but
they could also be deployed to take
control of a host of fast-moving health
crises the question is now what are you
looking for in that information from
this sewage that will allow us to see
information on for example if we have
viruses that are kind of becoming more
prevalent with regards to an epidemic or
maybe not even an epidemic just
basically an outbreak let's say like
influenza in an area
as researchers of MIT
continued efforts to shape the city of
the future they're constantly looking
for new ways to reveal more about the
city of today that's where we change
cities when we put different data from
different sources together which is why
the team has started talking rubbish
[Music]
Boston's garbage trucks travel the same
streets every week making them the
perfect vehicles for the collection of
constantly changing environmental data
this one's been equipped with
temperature sensors humidity sensors and
thermal imaging cameras the key check on
the energy efficiency of Boston's
buildings and the quality of the city
air although we do with technology and
we create technology here at a daily
basis we know that people are at the
core of the cities at the core Society
so it's only by making people these
matters but also sensitive that we can
create better series
whether it's city planners using data to
transform life from on high or citizens
using data to build solutions from the
ground up
they're finding new ways to use
technology to tackle the challenges
faced by modern-day mega cities they the
fallacy and making sense of this data
that we can change the cities of the
future
[Music]
you